how's it going everybody it's Warren and
in some awesome events today we have
some news in regards to spider-man a far
from home we have a new post credit
scene for spider-man far from home
entirely new footage of Jay jonah
Jameson talking about the identity
reveal of spider-man the true identity
of spider-man he's a high school kid in
Queens named Peter Parker a teenage
psychopath armed to the teeth a spare
man attacked me for some reason he is an
army weaponized drones wielding powers
he has no right to possess trying to
pass himself off as a hero you are a
criminal a menace and the good people
this nation will squash you like the bug
you are
J jonah Jameson here thanks for watching
don't forget to Like and subscribe so
there you have it a new post credit
scene that I assume was supposed to be
released but actually got cut obviously
this would have led off the first post
credit scene that we actually saw in the
movie and this was revealed by the
actual website The Daily Bugle net so no
doubt setting up the importance of J
jonah Jameson moving forward with
spider-man and if you caught my video
yesterday you know that he's actually
going to be a main pivotal character for
the Sony verse and the MCU connecting to
each other it's been reported that he is
going to be in the movie Morbius which
of course is Sony and will exist in the
Sony verse but J jonah Jameson exists in
the MCU therefore he is bringing the two
universes together we definitely know
that spider-man is going to be needing
some help in the next spider-man movie
perhaps he could get some help from Matt
Murdock aka daredevil or perhaps
Deadpool could step in but let me know
what you think about this new
post-credit scene and let me know who
you would like to see in the next
spider-man film help out Spidey let me
know down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 and
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to spider-man as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof